So, growing up, I didn't really see many female pilots or females or computer scientists.
Those are two of my passions, and it's quite discouraging...
...when there's no one that you know, can relate to that, does any of those things,...
...so then I wanted to fly around the world,...
...hopefully have other girls see me and think, "I'd love to fly one day too."
When she first told me about it, my heart skipped a beat,...
...and it took me a bit of time to digest, and now I'm so proud...
...and fully, fully behind her.
But as I said, mixed feelings.
Yeah, it's exciting.
It's really exciting.
I see the risk; I understand them.
So does she,...
...but I'm really proud of what she's doing, not just for herself...
...but also this, in a bid to level the playing field for women...
...getting into STEM and aviation, so I think it's fantastic.